hello and welcome to New World review
I'm Graham Lam waifu and i'm here to
steal your soul and wear it like a
beanie but you won't mind that because
it's been a long time coming and frankly
if you didn't know i was going to do
this by now you should be a little bit
embarrassed please keep your arms and
legs inside the review at all times or i
will take those too
i've been warned about threatening
people on mass so this threat is
directly aimed at the person editing
this video you know who you are yes that
guy right there no use a less flattering
picture of yourself it's only that
better you will find spoilers for
episodes 27 and 28 here here and here if
you want to register disapproval or
approval you will find buttons here and
here though i cannot guarantee the
button is safe to click with your mortal
mouse button hands to soothe you cute
dog face incoming in 3 2 1
bam that's all the cuteness you're going
to get so enjoy a zoo she wasn't as
heavily featured in these episodes
speaking of episodes we are in the rena
nanana nanan and phase of hunter hunter
in fact this episode of Hunter hunter is
called nimman in' so join me as we say
Nana nanana nanana nanan and it's
surprisingly satisfying as satisfying as
seeing his Sokka turn up just when I was
missing him most welcome back beloved
it's not at all surprising that his
Sookie uses 10 Ronin NN and that his nen
ergy to manipulate people it makes me
wonder whether what Gahan was sensing in
the forest during his exam was her
intense 10 usage him focusing his soul
into a single point but why would he cuz
it feels good I'd imagine it would
indeed feel good to focus ones dirty
dirty soul into a single point we've
seen him use his Jets verbally telling
illumine not to touch gone and it stands
to reason that just like chicken wing he
uses men to move the cards he carries it
gives more context overall in terms of
hisoka's flamenco actually it's a
counterpoint the flamenco is very
rigidly held to time in order to push
the passion through very specific
movements Hisoka very rigidly controls
his men through ren to then engage huts
if I'm using this right lots of words
anyway Bizet sees the main aspect of him
we haven't seen so far though chicken
did mention that it could be verbally or
physically carried out so now of course
we wonder what the relationship is
between Hasakah and wing did one train
the other i'll admit before we turned up
i was starting to think that perhaps
wing was Hisoka without makeup though i
can't in hindsight
imagine his
being able to pull off the ability to
train nor could he work with a young kid
without being really cruel sushi trust
swing enough that he doesn't question
wings lie at first so that was just an
inkling turning up another point that
definitely did not miss me was the fact
that wing had access to floor 200 and he
seemed to know that his Sokka or someone
like him would be there waiting for them
wing has completed the competition
before either winging I'm full of puns
today either wing it or by concentrated
and then probably both who taught him
how did he know his Sokka why did he
change his mind about them learning
about men especially knowing they were
on their way to the top why did he
change his mind about it and what is it
about men that meant zoo she could get
up after being hit full force by keel
speaking of kilowatt I'm very much
enjoying that we've maintained the focus
on him for this arc it seems strange
that a kid who turned up late to the
party in terms of episodes would be the
next focus but I really enjoy that the
spotlight has been placed on him we've
gone along for the ride I sense a really
big payoff when he sees his brother
again and can stand up to him or when he
sees his mother and can wait he's
already done that
like wing I suspect these two kids have
already been activating parts of their
adrenaline for long gone uses it's
constantly in his repetition of not
giving up Kiawah has a strong handle on
the concepts of ren and hudson as much
as the end of the episode was
questioning their ability to learn the
concepts in less than four hours i
didn't really have any doubt that they'd
be able to learn it the issue will come
when they experience burnout like wing
says can they maintain their souls do
these kids even have souls the nice
thing about seeing the interaction
between zhu xi and the gun killer combo
is that we see what a normal kid should
look like yes he has extraordinary
training but he's a normally functioning
kid psychologically gone and Kilwa have
extraordinary abilities and they're not
normally functioning children everyone
who is interacted with them has noted
that in some way so the stopping point
for them isn't going to be whether they
can learn the techniques or whether they
can endure it'll be how specific the
concept of a soul is in this world and
whether they burn out their souls before
they finished what they're trying to
finish and that's a fascinating Lee dark
way to tell a story because someone like
Goku yes I'm jumping to another series
for a second sorry Goku has a very pure
soul he fights to protect he fights for
good he fights for the honor and
enjoyment of fighting but he doesn't
want to
right - ha and that's wings point he
doesn't want to teach gone and quinoa
because he doesn't trust that they would
use the power he teaches them safely he
doesn't think that they would be
honorable or good or fight for the right
reasons and yet he's teaching them
anyway perhaps it's because of who he
knows they're up against which is how we
end up cycling back to his soca they
have to know each other and wing has to
know the kids will die if they can't
stand up to him is he doing it for the
kids or because he wants them to defeat
her soca at which point is he doing it
for the greater good or to soothe his
own soul he knows gone and Kilwa will
likely end up using the power for the
wrong reasons he's gonna do it anyway
and that's knowledge that we're going to
take into episode 29 episode our
intrepid anti-heroes have learned the
power of Renan ininin and then or at
least tenon in an end which is
incidentally the number of people they
need to defeat in order to battle the
important dudes at the top of the arena
we got another set of silhouettes today
I'm not sure how I feel about these
silhouettes are they designed to leave
me wondering they appear every time I
have been bombarded with silhouettes and
at first I might have thought there'd be
some kind of shadow puppet show but now
that is definitely not something that
will happen it also seems that besides
the first one back in the last arcs
opening discussion there's no real
reason to use the silhouettes other than
aesthetic which is fine the aesthetic is
nice but usually silhouettes are used to
conceal and these ones are revealed
almost immediately we don't get the
chance to think about them we don't get
the chance to wonder whether the people
are seeing might be those people that
information is immediately obvious and
provided incredibly quickly it's an odd
thing the pacing of this show not that
that's a bad thing just that it's a
strange thing there seems to be a rhythm
of slow set up a chunk of exposition or
explanation followed by oh look at that
the thing that should be really
difficult or impossible for anyone who
isn't a 12 year old sociopath is
suddenly really easy it's a hard thing
to reconcile when I think about it
because I don't strictly mind that it's
happening I'm just so very aware that
it's happening that I'm not sure how to
feel about it I'm not sure whether the
intention is for me to go to here duh of
course they can or oh no they won't
manage to do this in time this is truly
too much for them and I think that's the
point I don't actually know and I feel
like I should that aside the actual
awakening of their bodies reminded me of
basically every mindfulness activity
I've ever taken someone through and that
was quite nice having that realism find
your inner peace is a strange thing to
do to someone after you've said I will
awaken every cell in your body and you
will steam to death but you know what
I'm sure I've done that too maybe I
brand line waifu and more wing than
chicken the fact that he taught the
miscibility and made a point of saying
but like don't use it yet it's possibly
the only thing that could have
guaranteed they would indeed use it
immediately has he never met a child and
what is it with those silhouette turned
real strange people I mean a soak is
usually the strangest character we'll
see and I love him for his strangeness
but these guys just sort of stood around
watching and I feel like despite
hisoka's very clear creepster ick factor
these guys seem somewhat more dangerous
I find it difficult to believe that his
Soaker will leave gone unprotected here
he's not matured enough for his Soaker
as yet it's strange how far ahead it's
possible to see with this story gone
can't finish this arena until he's
strong enough to fight his soca at least
the theory goes in my head and his soca
can't let gondii until Kahn's finished
ripening as it were I've seen those
devil fruits limb creates on grand line
review it's it's like this is the
gone-gone fruit and his soak is just
waiting for it to ripen so he can enjoy
the delectable juices in LA but he has
to wait for God to gain his renin in and
then first and be able to manipulate it
speaking of Ronin when they first
introduced GaN and quinoa on the 200th
floor I thought they might be fighting
each other I was more interested than I
should have been by that prosper we know
or at least I hope we do that God could
absolutely not beat Kilauea in a fight
right now but I'd have liked to see them
navigate the social aspects of that
maybe they can be each other's tenth
fight that seems to be the most
significant possible outcome other than
fighting Hisoka and returning to my love
I do wonder since he knew where Gahan
was going whether he would have taught
gone or found a way to have gone taught
about 10 men then himself if gone hadn't
had winged turn up it's a lovely
coincidence that we have this boy and
his trainer who are in the opening
credits Thank You Liam to show Gahan the
ability Hisoka needs him to learn to be
a credible fruity threat a fruity threat
yes and to show killer how to be the
strongest he can be despite
his brother having the same knowledge
and ability to teach it too which is
another point why didn't kill Wyler miss
from his family he was taught how to do
the ghosty step thing that he tried to
teach kanayo
who already knew it I wonder whether she
knows about her Ninon and whether she
could theoretically have taught it to
him to all these people who could teach
them something and they either don't
need it or don't want it I suppose that
comes with the territory of being young
that receptionist woman by the way
deserves a bloody Oscar for the
performance she gave to those ungrateful
children she did everything she could to
make the experience fun for them she
gave them a very piece of her nen y'all
to create hype and enjoyment and pump
them up but no no you can tell that
she's someone who really wants to love
her job but up on the 200th floor I
don't think many people at all have the
level of hype they have down on the
earlier flaws assuming of course it's
not the same woman on all of them I mean
look at her and her and her is this an
officer Jenny thing I understand the
uniform but they have such similar
features that I wonder if maybe they're
related
that's a cross over with four different
franchises and that's before we hit up
the audio slice of life adventure and
caught up because Fight Club I think I'm
on to something here y'all and this is
the point where I should probably stop
talking because I'm not allowed to talk
about the club I'm not allowed to talk
about there's some stuff here for you to
click there's stuff here for you to
click I think there's a doobly-doo thing
down below but video for you to look at
please like subscribe and comment and
check out the grand line review discord
and click things and have fun and and
talk to me and stuff and I'll see you
next time